>> Okay.
Kay Leave, I've been asked to try and respond
to you.
And I think you are right on the money, or
a hammer on the nail or
whatever the right way of putting it.
As we see things at little old WPP are we
would expect 2009
actually be quite a different year.
I don't think I would say things necessarily
will recover in 2009
but the first half is gonna be pretty awful.
And second half, I think, will be as I look
at our budgets, the way we
look at things at this time in the year, are
pretty much flat revenues
from the year but certainly first half is
tougher and the second half
gets a little bit better, always things are
relative so the first half
and second half in 2009.
I think I'd expect 2010 to be, in the real
world at least, to be
a little better.
Here at Davos, if you take what the people
say here is being important
or serous, certainly serious, or whether it's
important or not, it
won't be saying as being pretty gloomy, pretty
pleasant less.
I think that's pretty uniformly in the case.
And I would be identified as an optimist.
ReVeene the colonist would be the probably
be the most negative talking
about latter part of 2010 is a recovery point
and the real world
or maybe later.
The other thing I think you will see is that
back half of 2009, second
half 2009, we'll see a recovery in the natural
markets.
And that recovery will be sharper than people
anticipated because of
this love of money on the side.
What are we have to do to get there?
Well, I think that the first fiscal stimulus,
the plans, stimulus,
people insisting on borrowing now is so great.
I think as I was seeing CNBC this morning
they were talking about the
as much as 8 trillion dollars being injected
into the U.S. economy
alone one way or another in the U.S. 14 trillion
dollars is about 40
trillion out about 32, 33 trillion around
the world.
So it's all depending on President Obama.
We have high hopes.
He's making very good noises and speedy noises
about putting in a -- a
stimulation package, one probably that won't
result -- won't be
increase taxes.
I think identified. I will be investing in
the right areas on
technology and productivity and competitiveness.
So I'm quite optimistic that we'll get that
short-term stimulus.
The U.S. I think will recover.
I think the big issue is Western Europe; France,
Germany, Italy, and
Spain and U.K. will have massive government
deficits. Kosovo increased
inflation and higher long-term interest rates
which won't be helpful.
And here we are having gone through recession
being asked to lend more
and spend more and long term solution is for
us to save more so the
past growing markets, will burst in the next
11, will spend more
because that's where the savings are and that's
where the capitalism
that's where the continued to be.
So I'm not glooming, not as gloomy as most
here.
And I'm looking for recovery in the year 2010
in real world and
financial world and back half of 2009.